best friends Mark Burnett and Roma
Downey are the Hollywood power couple
behind the 2016 historical action flick
Ben Hur a reimagining of the iconic 1959
version how long were you a slave 30s
what is your name better under 35
audience are really not the Ben Hur
generation
it's the Ben who generation which he
spends hastily you get to show his
incredible movie with the emotional
compelling moments in it I recently sat
down with the duo and one thing was
clear they're madly in love I'm sitting
here looking at you and you're just so
beautiful together as a couple
you're my relationship goals talk to me
about working together but also you know
going home together do you guys bring
work home are you always discussing it
do you leave it at the door I mean we're
best friends I mean in the end yeah
obviously we're in love and there's the
attraction and emotion but we're also
best friends and I think that's the most
important thing being part of the team
just been grateful to be to be included
as part of the team I know you shot the
film in Italy what were some of the fun
things you did in Italy together there
was eating and then there was no eating
and then we did some eating I must have
gained ten pose and weight but you
kidding that my wife always looks so
good
ben-hur is in theaters August 12th